Before we start today, this episode is about race and free speech. It includes sounds from the violence and Charlottesville, as well as a racial epithet. If you have small kids with you, please save this one for later. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantin. A few weeks ago, the words Charlottesville and Tiki torches weren't national symbols you'd associate with white supremacy. Today, those words convey a very specific scene. White lives men! White lives men! We begin with the deadly chaos on the streets of Charlottesville, Virginia.
在我们今天的节目开始之前，本期内容将探讨种族和言论自由。其中包含夏洛茨维尔暴力事件的现场声音以及种族歧视用语。如果您的身边有幼童，请稍后再收听。这里是《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹蒂姆。几周前，“夏洛茨维尔”和“蒂基火炬”还不是你会将之与白人至上主义联系在一起的国家符号。今天，这些词唤起的是一幕非常具体的场景。白人的命也是命！白人的命也是命！我们从弗吉尼亚州夏洛茨维尔街头的致命混乱开始说起。
Yesterday's dueling rallies turned deadly when a car plowed into a group of those who opposed the alt-right. It was a weekend of street battles and stark displays of racism. a weekend of street battles and stark displays of racism. Photos of enraged white men using the Nazi salute and marching with torches shocked many Americans. And since then, many of us have been doing a lot of soul searching. Who are we? What do we stand for? And as a nation, what do we tolerate? Today, we want to zoom in on a specific issue that grows out of the events in Charlottesville. The Constitution upholds the rights of Americans to say almost anything, no matter how distasteful, without censure from legislatures, the police, or the courts.
昨天针锋相对的集会在一辆汽车冲入反另类右翼人群后演变成命案。这是一个充满街头冲突和赤裸裸种族主义的周末，一个充满街头冲突和赤裸裸种族主义的周末。愤怒的白人男性行纳粹礼并举着火炬游行的照片震惊了许多美国人。自那时起，我们许多人一直在进行深刻的反省。我们是谁？我们代表什么？作为这个国家，我们容忍什么？今天，我们要聚焦于一个源自夏洛茨维尔事件的具体问题。宪法维护美国人几乎发表任何言论的权利，无论这些言论多么令人反感，都不会受到立法机关、警察或法院的审查。
Our protections for speech, even hate-filled, vitriolic speech go further than most nations. In recent weeks, many people have made free speech arguments to defend the white supremacists who descended on Charlottesville. Is hate speech protected under the Constitution in a word? Yes. Free speech may give them the right to do this, but are they not familiar with the First Amendment? There's a fine line between free speech and hate speech. But hold on, we can't have that conversation or any conversation until we both agree that Are they not familiar with the first amendment? There's a fine line between free speech and hate speech.
我们对言论的保护，甚至是对充满仇恨、尖酸刻薄言论的保护，比大多数国家都要走得更远。最近几周，许多人以言论自由为由，为涌入夏洛茨维尔的白人至上主义者辩护。仇恨言论受宪法保护吗？简而言之：是的。言论自由或许赋予了他们这样做的权利，但他们难道对第一修正案一无所知吗？言论自由和仇恨言论之间有一条细微的界限。但等等，在我们双方都同意以下观点之前，我们无法进行这场对话或任何对话：他们难道对第一修正案一无所知吗？言论自由和仇恨言论之间有一条细微的界限。
But hold on, we can't have that conversation or any conversation until we both agree that we have the right to say what we believe. And that we're not going to be punished for doing that right. Are these arguments motivated by principle or something less heroic? New psychological research suggests that people's motivations might not be what they seem. And that's true, no matter where you fall on the political spectrum. People pull out free speech as a defense when they're defending racist speech, but not when they're defending simply aggressive or negative speech. Today on Hidden Brain, what we're really saying when we say we defend free speech, and how the words we use and the things we say
但等等，在我们双方都同意我们有权表达我们的信仰，并且我们不会因行使这一权利而受到惩罚之前，我们无法进行这场对话或任何对话。这些论点是由原则驱动的，还是由某些不那么崇高的东西驱动的？新的心理学研究表明，人们的动机可能并非表面看起来那样。无论你在政治光谱上处于哪个位置，这都是事实。当人们为种族主义言论辩护时，他们会把言论自由拿出来当挡箭牌，但在为单纯的攻击性或消极言论辩护时则不会。今天在《隐藏大脑》中，我们将探讨当我们声称捍卫言论自由时真正表达了什么，以及我们使用的词汇和说出的话
shape the culture in which we live. Chris Krandel is a professor of psychology at the University of Kansas. He studies prejudice and has looked at how we use free speech claims. We spoke before the violence in Charlottesville, but we started by talking about an incident that echoes what happened there. In 2015, members of the Sigma Alpha Epsilon fraternity at the University of Oklahoma were caught on video singing a racist song. They were singing, there will never be a n-word in SAE and they were singing happily and clapping along about
如何塑造了我们生活的文化。克里斯·克兰德尔是堪萨斯大学的心理学教授。他研究偏见，并探讨了我们如何利用言论自由的诉求。我们在夏洛茨维尔的暴力事件发生前进行了采访，但我们的对话是从一个呼应那里发生的事情的事件开始的。2015年，堪萨斯大学西格玛阿尔法爱普生兄弟会的成员在唱种族主义歌曲时被视频拍了下来。他们唱道，SAE里永远不会有黑人，他们开心地唱着，并拍手庆祝
the exclusion of African Americans from the fraternity. The video of the song was put on Facebook and it spread around the campus and the two song leaders of the fraternity who were captured on video were expelled from the university and the fraternity itself was shut down on the campus of the University of Oklahoma and there was really a media firestorm about there singing the song. In the aftermath of the incident one of your graduate students noticed something unusual about the responses to the incident. What did he notice? Yeah, Mark White was following this on the internet and he looked at the tenor of the comments and people were saying, well this is simply free speech.
非洲裔美国人被排挤出兄弟会。这首歌的视频被发布到Facebook上，并在校园里传开，视频中被拍到的兄弟会两名领唱被学校开除，该兄弟会在堪萨斯大学的校园也被关闭，这首歌引发了一场真正的媒体风暴。事件发生后，你的一位研究生注意到对该事件的反应有些不同寻常。他注意到了什么？是的，马克·怀特在互联网上关注此事，他观察了评论的基调，人们说，这纯粹是言论自由。
These people have a right to say these things because Americans have the right to free speech. But underneath the surface, in the background, or sometimes right at the forefront, it really looked like what people were doing was justifying the content of what was said, not the fact that they have the right to say something freely, but rather that they seem to be justifying the racist speech itself by giving an account, hey, free speech, that allowed them to do that without punishment. Now, it's worth pointing out, of course,
这些人有权说这些话，因为美国人拥有言论自由的权利。但在表面之下、背景之中，或者有时甚至直接在最显眼的地方，人们真正做的实际上是在为所说内容的正当性辩护，而不是在捍卫他们自由说话的权利，相反，他们似乎是在为种族主义言论本身提供理由，通过借口“嘿，这是言论自由”，从而允许他们在不受惩罚的情况下说出这些话。现在，值得指出的是，
that the First Amendment protects people against government intrusions on free speech. It doesn't actually prevent private companies or universities from deciding what is or isn't acceptable speech in the workplace or on a college campus. But setting aside that distinction, you conducted an experiment where you had volunteers listen to racially charged commentary and you evaluated whether they would reach for free speech arguments to defend it.
第一修正案保护人们免受政府对言论自由的干涉。它实际上并没有阻止私营公司或大学决定工作场所或大学校园内什么是或什么不是可以接受的言论。但撇开这种区别不谈，你做了一个实验，让志愿者听取带有种族色彩的评论，并评估他们是否会搬出言论自由的论点来为其辩护。
You evaluated whether people who endorse free speech arguments do so consistently or they do so selectively. What walked me through the experiment? Yeah, so in one version of the experiment, we did several of these. In one version of the experiment, people read about somebody who wrote something on Facebook that was a deeply racist.
你评估了支持言论自由论点的人是始终如一地这样做，还是有选择性地这样做。能为我介绍一下这个实验吗？好的，在实验的一个版本中，我们做了好几个这样的实验。在其中一个版本的实验中，人们阅读了关于某人在Facebook上写下具有深刻种族主义色彩内容的故事。
For example, a barista wrote on Facebook that the black customers were problematic, that they were noisy and rude and other racially stereotypic actions. And the people in the study read that the person had been fired for posting this racist speech. In the other condition, people read about a guy complaining about customers, but no racial information was given.
例如，一名咖啡师在Facebook上写道，黑人顾客是个麻烦，他们吵闹、粗鲁，并且有其他符合种族刻板印象的行为。研究中的参与者读到这个人因为发布这些种族主义言论而被解雇了。在另一种情况下，人们读到的是一个人在抱怨顾客，但没有给出任何种族信息。
So the same boisterous, aggressive, loud, cutting-in line behavior was described, but the racial element was eradicated. And so the question was, do racial attitudes of our participants determine how much they're going to defend the speaker? In the racialized condition, the more you had negative attitudes towards African Americans, the stronger you endorsed free speech as a justification for why the person should have been able to say that without being fired. So that suggests that racial attitudes might be behind free speech defense. But you might say quite easily, that's simply a correlation. I'm not impressed.
因此，描述了同样喧闹、具有攻击性、大声喧哗、插队的行为，但消除了种族因素。所以问题是，我们参与者的种族态度是否决定了他们会多大程度上为演讲者辩护？在带有种族色彩的情况下，你对非洲裔美国人的负面态度越多，你就越强烈地支持言论自由，以此作为这个人应该能够说这些话而不被解雇的理由。这表明种族态度可能是言论自由辩护背后的原因。但你很容易会说，这只是一种相关性。我并不买账。
Maybe people who have negative racial attitudes are also libertarians, and they believe that free speech is super important and they're just simply expressing that. The problem with that argument is when you remove the racial content from the story, so in the condition whether the guy complains about customers, but there's no racial element, racial attitudes correlate zero with free speech defense.
也许那些持有负面种族态度的人也是自由意志主义者，他们认为言论自由超级重要，他们只是在表达这一点。这个论调的问题在于，当你从故事中去除种族内容时，也就是在那个抱怨顾客但没有种族元素的版本中，种族态度与言论自由辩护之间的相关性为零。
It seems that people pull them out and deploy them when they're appropriate. So people pull out free speech as a defense when they're defending racist speech, but not when they're defending simply aggressive or negative speech. I understand that one of the ways in which you measured racial attitudes was simply to ask people what are your attitudes to what people from different races. Yeah, people are a little careful in how they speak about racial attitudes, but our participants were willing to say that they thought that blacks were pushing too hard for their equal rights and that blacks were getting more than they deserved.
似乎人们只在合适的时候才把它们搬出来部署。因此，当人们在为种族主义言论辩护时，会把言论自由拿出来当盾牌，但在为单纯的攻击性或消极言论辩护时则不会。据我所知，你衡量种族态度的方法之一就是直接询问人们对不同种族的人有什么态度。是的，人们在谈论种族态度时会有点小心翼翼，但我们的参与者愿意承认，他们认为黑人为争取平等权利过于激进，黑人得到的比他们应得的要多。
And in some cases, we simply had them rate African-Americans under a zero to 100 scale. And the lower the number you gave, the more you used the free speech defense in defense of racist speech. One of the elements of the study that you conducted asked people about their attitudes about police officers. I find it's not correctly you were measuring controversial speech as it was directed towards a minority group versus controversial speech directed against police officers. Yeah, in the police version, we were interested in not only attitudes towards African-American, so somebody said something racist, but we also thought that police might be the exact opposite. That is, people who might be very anti-African-American might be particularly pro-police. And certainly in
在某些情况下，我们只是让他们在零到一百的尺度上对非洲裔美国人进行评分。你给出的数字越低，你在为种族主义言论辩护时就越多地使用言论自由的辩护理由。你进行的这项研究的要素之一，是询问人们对警官的态度。如果我没记错的话，你是在衡量针对少数族裔的争议性言论与针对警察的争议性言论。是的，在关于警察的版本中，我们不仅对针对非洲裔美国人的态度感兴趣，即某人说了种族主义的话，而且我们还认为警察可能是完全相反的情况。也就是说，那些非常反非洲裔美国人的人可能特别支持警察。当然在
history of the Midwest here in St. Louis and in Missouri just across the border, there have been a lot of police African-American interactions that have not been very happy. So we thought if we used the police, maybe you'd get the opposite effect. And we did, it wasn't as strong, but we did find that the more a person had negative attitudes towards African Americans, the less they defended anti-police speech. Although in the other condition, the more they defended the free speech of racist commenters. So in other words, if the speech is basically anti-black, someone with high racial animus might say that speech is permissible and the First Amendment free speech grounds, but if the speech is
中西部这里的圣路易斯以及密苏里州边界附近的历史中，有很多警察与非洲裔美国人之间并不那么愉快的互动。所以我们想，如果我们使用警察作为对象，也许你会得到相反的效果。我们确实得到了这样的结果，虽然没有那么强烈，但我们确实发现，一个人对非洲裔美国人的负面态度越多，他们对反警察言论的辩护就越少。尽管在另一种情况下，他们越是为种族主义评论者的言论自由辩护。换句话说，如果言论基本上是反黑人的，一个具有高度种族敌意的人可能会以言论自由的第一修正案为由说这种言论是允许的，但如果言论是
anti-police, the person might say, I don't really agree with this person expressing these kinds of views, so the person is inconsistent in their defense of free speech. That's right. This is what we find is that people are really inconsistent. You also found in the experiment, Chris, that it wasn't just people with racial biases who were sometimes hypocritical when it came to free speech issues. You also found that people who were low in racial bias were also hypocritical just in the opposite direction. Yes, people who were low in racial prejudice were just as inconsistent in applying the first amendment as a defense than people who were high in racial prejudice. When they were asked to use the first amendment to defend racist speech, they actually reduced their willingness to do it. They would defend the free speech
反警察的，这个人可能会说，我真的不同意这个人表达这种观点，因此这个人对言论自由的辩护前后不一。没错。我们发现的情况是，人们真的很不一致。克里斯，你在实验中还发现，在言论自由问题上虚伪的不仅仅是那些带有种族偏见的人。你还发现，种族偏见较低的人在相反的方向上也同样虚伪。是的，种族偏见较低的人在运用第一修正案作为辩护时，与种族偏见较高的人一样前后不一。当被要求使用第一修正案来为种族主义言论辩护时，他们实际上降低了这样做的意愿。他们会以平均水平
of somebody who was complaining about their customers or police at an average level. But when it became racialized, the low racist people actually walked away from the First Amendment defense. They went substantially lower. This suggests that when people are using the free speech defense, they know what they're doing because the high racists use it in defense of racist speech and the low racists drop it like a hot potato and say, no, no, no, no, no, we're not defending the speech with First Amendment. But they would defend a barista who's complaining about his or her customers or the police. When you found people defending the racist speech on First Amendment grounds, on freedom of expression grounds, is this because people may have at some level felt bad about themselves? Chris, they felt
去捍卫那些抱怨顾客或警察的人的言论自由。但当事情带有种族色彩时，种族偏见低的人实际上会抛弃第一修正案的辩护。他们的意愿大大降低了。这表明，当人们使用言论自由作为辩护时，他们知道自己在做什么，因为种族偏见高的人用它来为种族主义言论辩护，而种族偏见低的人则像扔烫手山芋一样抛弃它，并说，不，不，不，不，我们不是在用第一修正案捍卫这种言论。但他们会为抱怨自己顾客或警察的咖啡师辩护。当你发现人们以第一修正案为由、以表达自由为由为种族主义言论辩护时，这是因为人们在某种程度上对自己的看法感到不好吗？克里斯，他们感到
bad that the person who has views similar to their own is being punished in some way and they're trying to defend that person as a way to defend themselves. That's exactly what we thought was going on and when we started showing these studies, everybody would nod when we say, and so maybe they're defending themselves. But we did several studies where we tried to find out if people's self-esteem was attacked by this, if they needed help to feel good about themselves. And we could never find evidence that people were defending themselves. What we found evidence for was that people were defending their right to say things. They were defending the speech so that their future speech would be protective. They wanted to create a world where this kind of prejudicial speech was acceptable for them to say, for others to say in the future.
不好是因为持有与他们相似观点的人以某种方式受到了惩罚，他们试图通过为那个人辩护来为自己辩护。这正是我们认为正在发生的事情，当我们开始展示这些研究时，当我们说“也许他们是在为自己辩护”时，每个人都会点头。但我们做了几项研究，试图找出人们的自尊心是否因此受到攻击，他们是否需要通过辩护来感觉良好。然而我们从未找到证据表明人们是在为自己辩护。我们找到证据支持的是，人们是在捍卫自己说话的权利。他们是在捍卫言论，以便他们未来的言论能够受到保护。他们想要创造这样一个世界：这种偏见言论对他们自己或未来其他人来说是可以接受的。
How would you respond to people who might say, you know, let's look under the hood of Chris Crandell's brain. Isn't it possible he's just a lefty academic who's coming up with research findings that endorse his own pre-existing views of how the world works? I think that some of that criticism would probably land. I am sort of a lefty academic. I'm a little bit more centrist, I suppose, but we were interested in studying prejudice because prejudice is a particular social problem. It shows up all around the country, it affects people's lives, and so we studied that. But people would be inconsistent about, for example, being environmentalist and failing to recycle or going too fast in the right-hand lane of a highway. People are inconsistent all the time, and they manage to get over that pretty easily,
你将如何回应那些可能会说“让我们一探克里斯·克兰德尔大脑究竟”的人？难道他不是一个左翼学者，炮制出符合其对世界运作方式既有看法的研究成果吗？我认为这种批评有一部分可能会说中。我确实算是一个左翼学者。我想我更倾向于中间派一点，但我们对研究偏见感兴趣，因为偏见是一个特定的社会问题。它在全国各地出现，影响着人们的生活，所以我们对此进行了研究。但人们在其他事情上也会前后不一，例如支持环保但未能回收利用，或者在高速公路的最右侧车道超速行驶。人们总是前后不一，而且他们很容易就能克服这一点，
mostly by being unaware of it or not paying attention to it too much. When we come back, we look at the effect of free speech arguments on our behavior. I'm also going to ask Chris about how the language we use and the things we say can reshape our culture, especially when the person doing the talking is the president. I could stand in the middle of fifth day of the new and shoot somebody and I wouldn't
主要是通过对此毫无所觉或不太关注。当我们回来时，我们将探讨言论自由论点对我们行为的影响。我还将问克里斯，我们使用的语言和说出的话如何能够重塑我们的文化，尤其是当说话的人是总统时。我甚至可以站在第五大道的中间开枪打死一个人，而不会
lose any voters, okay? It's like an incredible. It's not so much what's in your head and heart as it is, you looking around and seeing what's acceptable, seeing what's okay, seeing what people will tolerate, and the election changed people's notion of what was tolerable. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantin. If you're a parent, your kid might have one of those inflatable punching bag toys.
失去任何选民，好吗？这与其说取决于你脑海和心中有什么，不如说取决于你环顾四周并看到什么是可以接受的、什么是没问题的、人们会容忍什么，而这场选举改变了人们对什么是可容忍的看法。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹蒂姆。如果你是一位父母，你的孩子可能拥有那种充气不倒翁玩具。
Sometimes it's a clown, sometimes it's a shark, or like the one in this YouTube video, an inflatable Spider-Man. The thing that kids love about these toys is that they can punch them over and over, and the toys keep bouncing back. They're weighed down, usually with sand, and they can take all kinds of abuse. These toys, which are known as bobo dolls, were used in a famous psychology experiment in the 1960s. The researcher Albert Bandura had kids watch as a person repeatedly hit a bobo doll with a hammer. I let research a Chris Crandel pick up the story from here.
有时它是一个小丑，有时它是一只鲨鱼，或者像这个YouTube视频里的那样，是一个充气的蜘蛛侠。孩子们喜欢这些玩具的地方在于，他们可以一遍又一遍地击打它们，而玩具会不断反弹。它们的底部通常加了沙子，能够承受各种各样的击打。这些被称为波波玩偶的玩具在20世纪60年代的一项著名心理学实验中被使用过。研究人员阿尔伯特·班杜拉让孩子们看着一个人用锤子反复击打波波玩偶。我让研究人员克里斯·克兰德尔从这里开始接管故事。
Now what Banderah had his children watch was somebody who came in, went and grabbed a hammer, straddled the bobo doll so that it was lying on the ground, and then hit it in the face with a hammer, saying punch him in the face, hit him with a hammer. Afterwards, sometimes what he called the model, the person doing the punching, was punished, sometimes nothing happened at all, sometimes they were rewarded. The children were then put in a room filled with toys, and over in the corner, a bobo doll,
现在班杜拉让他的孩子们观看的是，一个人走进来，拿了一把锤子，跨坐在不倒翁娃娃上使其平躺在地上，然后用锤子击打它的脸，边打边说“打他的脸，用锤子打他”。之后，有时他称之为模特的这个人（即进行击打的人）会受到惩罚，有时什么也没发生，有时他们会得到奖励。随后，孩子们被带到一个放满玩具的房间里，在角落里有一个不倒翁娃娃，
and elsewhere in the room, a hammer. The kids who had seen the model either have no consequence at all or be rewarded quickly when over. Grab the hammer, got the bobo doll into the middle of the room and started immediately pounding it about the face with the hammer and repeating punch them in the face, hit him with a hammer. The kids who had seen the model be punished did not do this at all. But here's the trick. Banderro wisely said at the end of this, you know, if you saw something in that video that interested you, you should know you won't be punished for this. At this point a majority of the kids get a
房间的另一头有一把锤子。那些看到模特没有受到任何惩罚或很快得到奖励的模仿者们，跑过去拿起锤子，把不倒翁娃娃拖到房间中央，立刻开始用锤子猛砸它的脸，并重复着“打他们的脸，用锤子打他”。而那些看到模特受到惩罚的孩子则完全没有这样做。但关键在这里。班杜拉在最后明智地说道：“你知道，如果你在视频中看到了让你感兴趣的东西，你应该知道你不会因此受到惩罚。”此时，大多数孩子脸上都露出了
look of glee on their face, run over, grab the bobo doll, grab the hammer, and start beating it about the face and straddling it and doing what they'd seen the model do. The moral of the story is that we learn from what people do and sometimes we don't do it. We may want to punch the bobo doll, but we know that we'll be punished for it. If somebody comes in and says, it's okay, you can use that hammer and bobo doll. They will gleefully run and grab the tools and start beating the face of the bobo doll. So what do Albert Bandora and the bobo dolls have to do with free speech? The link here has to do with social norms and what's permissible and not permissible. Chris Krandel conducted a study in the lead up to the 2016 presidential election.
喜悦的表情，跑过去，抓住不倒翁娃娃，拿起锤子，开始猛击它的脸，跨坐在它身上，做着他们看到模特做过的动作。这个故事的寓意是，我们通过观察别人的行为来学习，有时我们克制自己不做。我们可能想打不倒翁娃娃，但我们知道我们会为此受到惩罚。如果有人走进来，说“没关系，你可以用那把锤子和不倒翁娃娃”，他们就会兴高采烈地跑过去拿起工具，开始猛击不倒翁娃娃的脸。那么，阿尔伯特·班杜拉和不倒翁娃娃与言论自由有什么关系呢？这里的联系在于社会规范以及什么是允许的和不允许的。克里斯·克兰德尔在2016年总统大选前夕进行了一项研究。
He looked at both liberals and conservatives and asked them a series of questions. We were interested in what prejudices people had and we also wanted to ask them what they thought it was okay to express in the world. So we asked them about Muslims, Canadians, blind people, immigrants, women, and we asked them, how do you feel about them on a zero to 100 scale and the lower the number, the less you like them. But other people, we asked them, what do you think is okay to express in the US? And we asked them about all the same groups, Muslims, Canadians, blind people, and so on. So we were able to find out not only what people say they have
他同时调查了自由派和保守派，并向他们提出了一系列问题。我们对人们有什么偏见很感兴趣，我们也想问问他们，他们认为在世界上表达哪些观点是可以接受的。于是我们问了他们关于穆斯林、加拿大人、盲人、移民、妇女的看法，我们问他们：在零到一百的尺度上，你对他们感觉如何？数字越低，说明你越不喜欢他们。但对于其他人，我们问他们：你认为在美国表达什么观点是可以接受的？我们询问了所有相同的群体，穆斯林、加拿大人、盲人等等。因此，我们不仅能找出人们口中的偏见是什么，
as prejudices, but what they think is acceptable to express in the US. You brought the same people back after the election and you asked them the same questions. What did they say? For both Trump conservative supporters and Clinton more liberal supporters, we found that they thought the nation had changed substantially in what it was okay to express as a prejudice. For the groups that Trump had actually targeted in his campaign, Muslims.
还能找出他们认为在美国什么样偏见的表达是可以接受的。你在大选后把同一批人请了回来，问了他们同样的问题。他们是怎么说的？对于特朗普的保守派支持者和克林顿的自由派支持者，我们都发现，他们认为国家在“表达偏见的可接受性”方面发生了巨大变化。对于特朗普在竞选期间实际针对的群体，比如穆斯林。
I think Islam hates us. Mexicans. They're bringing drugs. They're bringing crime. They're rapists. Illegal immigrants. They beat us at the border. People are flowing through.
我认为伊斯兰教恨我们。墨西哥人。他们带来了毒品。他们带来了犯罪。他们是强奸犯。非法移民。他们在边境击败了我们。源源不断的人涌入进来。
Drugs are coming across, pouring across. Fat people. Only Rosie O'Donnell. There was a significant increase in how acceptable it was to express prejudice towards them. The interesting thing is, there was no change in the acceptability of prejudice towards groups that Trump had not aimed his prejudice at blind people, Canadians, and so on. What do you draw from the experiment, Chris? I mean, it seems remarkable that in a matter of weeks, you know, from stage one to stage two of your experiment,
毒品正从四面八方涌入。肥胖的人。只有罗西·奥唐纳。对于表达针对他们的偏见的可接受程度，出现了显著的增加。有趣的是，对于特朗普没有将其作为偏见目标的群体（盲人、加拿大人等），表达偏见的可接受性没有任何变化。克里斯，你从这个实验中得出了什么结论？我的意思是，这似乎很了不起，在短短几周内，你知道，从你的实验的第一阶段到第二阶段，
people's views of what they consider acceptable are changing. Yes, it was really only about 10 days, two weeks, and we don't think that anybody changed their hearts and minds in that time. What we think is that the election of Donald Trump changed people's understanding of what America felt. The election of Donald Trump, despite all of his overt expressions of prejudice, meant that it must be okay in America to have these prejudices. And so their scores on the acceptability of prejudice for the Trump-targeted groups went up, but not the ones he didn't target. The interesting thing about this is that people's own prejudices did not go up following their sense that America accepted it.
人们对什么被认为是可接受的看法正在改变。是的，实际上大约只有10天到两周的时间，我们认为在这段短时间内没有人改变了他们的内心和想法。我们认为的是，唐纳德·特朗普的当选改变了人们对美国社会氛围的理解。唐纳德·特朗普的当选，尽管他公开表达了种种偏见，但这意味着在美利坚合众国，持有这些偏见一定是没问题的。因此，他们对特朗普目标群体的偏见可接受性得分上升了，但对于他未针对的群体则没有上升。有趣的是，在人们感受到美国社会接受偏见之后，他们自身的偏见并没有上升。
And in fact, to a small degree, our participants, both Trump supporters and Clinton supporters, said they went down a little bit in prejudice just a little bit. And what we think is going on is that they looked around, saw the acceptability of prejudice, saw in America how much there really was, more than they thought, and they said to themselves, oh, I'm less prejudice than I thought I was. I must be okay, because there's a lot more prejudice out there than I thought. Dude, it's tricuous as remarkable that things change so quickly. I mean, I think most of us think about social norms
事实上，在某种程度上，我们的参与者——无论是特朗普的支持者还是克林顿的支持者——都表示他们的偏见略有下降，只下降了一点点。我们认为发生的情况是，他们环顾四周，看到了表达偏见的可接受性，看到了美国社会中这种偏见实际上有多么普遍，比他们想象的要多，然后他们对自己说：“哦，我比自己想象的要少一些偏见。我一定没问题，因为外面的偏见比我想象的要多得多。”老兄，这太离奇了，事情变化得如此之快真是不可思议。我的意思是，我想我们大多数人都认为社会规范
as being relatively stable and enduring things. They're the things that are acceptable in a country or a society. One day are probably gonna be the same things that are acceptable tomorrow or next week. And you're finding there was a dramatic change. Was it just the scale of the election, the fervor of the election that you think
是相对稳定和持久的东西。它们是一个国家或社会中可以接受的事物。今天可以接受的事物，明天或下周也可能是可以接受的。而你发现这里发生了巨大的变化。仅仅是大选的规模、大选的热情，你认为这才是造成差异的原因吗？还是你认为实际上社会规范非常具有可塑性，它们可以相当快地发生变化？你说得对，大多数规范都是稳定的，尤其是那些存在了很长时间、且在美国与偏见相关的规范一样公开的规范。但这有点不同。首先，总统大选以及对特朗普和偏见的报道规模巨大。大众媒体以及围绕特朗普及其对种族群体、移民群体、肥胖人群等的讨论的个人讨论，是一次巨大的干预。
might have made the difference? Or do you think that actually social norms actually are very malleable, and they can change fairly quickly? You're right that most norms are stable, especially ones that have been around a long time and are as public as prejudice norms in the US. But this is a little bit different. First of all, the presidential election and coverage of Trump and prejudice was massive. The mass media and personal discussion over Trump and his discussion of racial groups, immigrant groups, fat people and so on was a huge intervention.
其次，人们惊讶于美国公众通过选举他来批准这种做法。当然，这并不是指普选票，但仅仅赢得总统职位本身就可能会对社会规范产生影响。但这种社会规范的一个关键区别在于，有大量的美国人一直在压抑他们的偏见，一直在克制自己，他们不会说出自己真正的感受，因为他们知道这会受到惩罚。这就是政治正确的意思。人们有着消极的态度，但他们不会大声说出来，因为他们知道这些态度是不受欢迎的。
Second of all, people were surprised that the American public approved of it by electing him. Now of course it wasn't the popular vote but still winning the presidency alone is likely to have an effect on social norms. But one key difference with this social norm is that there is a large number of Americans who are suppressing their prejudice, who were holding it back, who wouldn't say what they really felt because they knew it would be punished. This is what is meant by political correctness. People have attitudes that are negative, but they don't say them out loud because they know that they're unpopular.
特朗普的当选消除了这种压抑。对于那些一直在极力压抑自己情感的人来说，这是一个打开闸门的一把钥匙，哪怕只开了一小部分。这就是为什么仇恨犯罪的数量似乎在选举后立即激增，而不是在所有言论都存在的选举前激增，而是在国家似乎赞同特朗普的偏见之后。所以这几乎是一个平行现象，与班杜拉实验有着诡异的平行，因为你所说的是，仅仅看到模特用锤子击打不倒翁娃娃是不够的。这并不是真正导致儿童随后模仿成人的原因。实际上是看到模特身上发生了什么。
The election of Trump removed the suppression. It was a key that opened up the floodgates just a little bit for people who had been suppressing their feelings a lot. And that's why the number of hate crimes seems to have jumped right after the election, not before when the speech was all there, but after when the nation seemed to approve of Trump's prejudices. So it's almost, you know, a parallel, this eerie parallel to the Bandoorestety, because what you're saying is it's not enough just to see the model strike the Bobo doll with the hammer. That isn't what actually causes the children to then imitate the adult. It's actually seeing what happens to the model.
在他或她对不倒翁娃娃做了这些之后，模特是得到了奖励，还是受到了惩罚？正是这种后续行动决定了儿童是模仿模特还是不模仿模特。完全正确。这不在于你脑海和心中有什么，而在于你环顾四周，看看什么是可以接受的，看看什么是没问题的，看看人们会容忍什么。
After he or she does that to the bubble doll, does the model get rewarded, does the model get punished? It's that action that then determines whether the children imitate the model or don't imitate the model. That's exactly right. It's not so much what's in your head and heart as it is you looking around and seeing what's acceptable, seeing what's okay, seeing what people will tolerate.
而这场选举改变了人们对什么是可容忍的看法。我想知道这项研究是否与你做过的其他关于“真实性”的研究有什么联系。你发现我们所有人都渴望真实的政治家，这无疑是唐纳德·特朗普的一大吸引力。但有时你曾论证过，或者你的研究发现，真实性是一种表达更微妙感受的方式。是的，人们说唐纳德·特朗普非常真实，我们想知道这其实可能有两种走向。一种是，我们认为他是真实的，因为他说了一些不受欢迎的话。通过说出违背社会规范的话，我们看到他在揭示
And the election changed people's notion of what was tolerable. I'm wondering if this research has any connection with some other work that you've done, looking at the question of authenticity. You found that we all crave politicians who are authentic and certainly that was one of the big appeals of Donald Trump. But sometimes you've argued or your research has found that authenticity is a way to express more subtle feelings. Yeah, people said that Donald Trump was very authentic and we wondered there's really two ways that that could go. One is that we think he's authentic because he says things that are unpopular. And by saying things that are counter to the social norms, we see that he's revealing
关于他自己的一些与其他人不同的东西。说你喜欢冰淇淋其实暴露了关于你自己的很少信息，但说我认为冰淇淋不好吃，则暴露了你相当多的信息，因为它是如此不寻常和不合常规。在偏见这个案例中，我们想知道人们是否认为他是真实的，因为他在说这些可怕的话，虽然他们认为这些话很可怕，但天哪，至少他说了出来。坦白说，我没有时间去搞什么绝对的政治正确。说实话，这个国家也没有时间。
something about himself that's different from every other person. To say that you like ice cream is to reveal very little about yourself, but to say that I don't think ice cream is any good, reveals quite a lot about you because it's so unusual and so atypical. With the case of prejudice, we wondered if maybe people thought he was authentic because he was saying these horrible things that they thought were horrible, but holy cow, at least he says it. I don't frankly have time for total political correctness. And to be honest with you, this country doesn't have time either.
这是一种可能性。另一种可能性恰恰相反。也就是说，真实性实际上只是一种代名词，意思是：你在表达我内心的偏见。一个真实的人就是当我自己无法表达时，能说出我心中感受的人。听到这个批评的特朗普支持者可能会说，他们被逼入了绝境。仅仅因为他们相信特朗普是真实的，或者他们信仰言论自由的保护，并不自动意味着他们是藏在暗处的种族主义者。
That's one possibility. The other possibility is exactly the opposite. And that is, authenticity is really just code words for saying, you are saying the prejudice that I have. An authentic person is somebody who says what I feel when I can't see it myself. Trump supporters who listen to this critique might say that they are being boxed into a corner. Just because they believe that Trump is authentic or they believe in free speech protections, doesn't automatically mean that they're closet racist.
这是一个合理的批评。我们对特朗普感兴趣的原因是，我们有兴趣试图解释美国人是如何能够容忍他的种族主义的。我想我们社会科学界的大多数人对特朗普当选感到惊讶，不是因为他的政治观点，而是因为他的种族主义、他对移民的态度、他对反肥胖的偏见、他的厌女症，似乎并没有阻止大多数美国人或许多
That's a fair criticism. The reason we are interested in Trump is that we are interested in trying to explain how Americans were able to tolerate his racism. I think that most of us in the social science community were surprised that Trump was elected not because of his politics, but because his racism, his attitudes towards immigrants, his anti-fat prejudice, his misogyny, didn't seem to stop most Americans or many
美国人投票支持他。这就是我们试图解释的问题。虚伪并不是自由派或保守派特有的东西。这是人类非常普遍的行为。但针对偏见的公共政策意义，而且我们是偏见研究人员，这就是我们选择以这种方式看待特朗普和真实性的原因。这项研究接下来将走向何方？你们是否仍在试图寻找方法来研究社会规范是否在继续发生变化，
Americans from voting for him. And that's the question that we're trying to explain. It's not particularly a liberal or conservative thing to be hypocritical. It's a very human thing to do that. But the public policy implications for prejudice, and we are prejudice researchers, is why we chose to look at Trump and authenticity in this way. Where does the research go from here? And are you still trying to figure out ways to study if social norms are continuing to change
随着我们离2016年大选越来越远？我们一直在追踪那些在选举时接受过调查的同一批人。我们发现的是，偏见的社会规范变得更加容忍偏见，甚至超出了特朗普针对的范围。所以坏消息是，随着时间的推移，所有的偏见似乎都变得在某种程度上更容易被接受了。克里斯·克兰德尔是堪萨斯大学的心理学家。克里斯，非常感谢你今天来到《隐形大脑》节目。
as we move further and further from the 2016 election? We've been following some of the same people that we followed at the election. And what we have found is that the norms for prejudice are becoming more tolerant of prejudice, even beyond what Trump targeted. So the bad news is that it seems that all prejudices are becoming somewhat more acceptable as the course goes on. Chris Krandel is a psychologist at the University of Kansas. Chris, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
谢谢你，尚卡尔。《隐形大脑》由珍妮·施密特、玛吉·佩恩曼、雷娜·科恩、蕾妮·克劳尔和帕思·沙阿制作。我们的监督制作人是塔拉·博伊尔。由珍妮·施密特、玛吉·佩恩曼、雷娜·科恩、蕾妮·克劳尔和帕思·沙阿制作。我们的监督制作人是塔拉·博伊尔。本期节目由露西·帕金斯制作，她轮流加入我们几周。她现在正前往奥地利进行学术访问。露西是一位总是火力全开的制作人，我们对她
Thank you, Shankar. Hidden Brain is produced by Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Pennman, Raina Cohen, Renée Claure, and Parth Sha. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. produced by Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Penman, Raina Cohen, Renee Clarre and Parth Shah. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. This episode of the show was produced by Lucy Perkins, who joined us on a rotation for a few weeks. She is now off to Austria on a fellowship. Lucy is the sort of producer who consistently fires on all cylinders, and we are so impressed
在与我们共事期间所做的一切印象深刻。谢谢你，露西。我们本周的无名英雄是杰玛·胡利。在与我们共事期间所做的一切印象深刻。谢谢你，露西。我们本周的无名英雄是杰玛·胡利。杰玛是NPR会员合作关系的副总裁。她负责监督与全国各地电台互动的团队，并帮助将最好的公共广播节目带到您当地的广播电台。杰玛的办公室就在我们的策划板旁边，所以她经常在不知情的情况下听到我们在规划未来节目的会议。我们将推出广播版的《隐形大脑》
by all she's done in her time with us. Thanks Lucy. Our unsung hero this week is Gemma Huli. by all she's done in her time with us. Thanks Lucy. A rungsang hero this week is Gemma Huli. Gemma is the vice president of member partnership here at NPR. She oversees the team that interacts with stations across the country and she helps bring the best of public radio programming to your local airwaves. Gemma's office is right next to our planning board, so she's often unwittingly subjected to our meetings as we plan for upcoming episodes. We're launching a radio version of Hidden Brain
今年秋天，杰玛的领导力是该项目顺利推出的原因之一。下周，我们将探讨遗憾。为什么我们的思维会被杂乱、混乱、战战兢兢之类的思维所吸引，为什么这有时可能是一件好事。当我了解更多时，我真正开始意识到遗憾其实是一种非常充满希望的情绪。我是尚卡尔·维达安塔，这是NPR广播电台。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
this fall, and Gemma's leadership is one of the reasons that launch is going smoothly. Coming up next week, we're going to look at regret. Why are minds are drawn to kudder, woodder, shudder kinds of thinking, and why this might sometimes be a good thing. As I learned more, I really started to realize that regret is actually a very hopeful emotion. I'm Sean Carvita Anton, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
今年秋天，杰玛的领导能力是发布工作进展顺利的原因之一。下周，我们将探讨“后悔”。为什么人们的思维会被“应该”、“本可以”、“本该”之类的想法所吸引，以及为什么这有时可能是一件好事。随着我了解得越多，我真正开始意识到，后悔其实是一种充满希望的情感。我是肖恩·卡维塔·安东，这里是美国国家公共电台。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。